your Flula that's awesome dude after you
watch the UFC and you saw Francis and
gone oh did you see if you can make 205
that's a lot of people like I could make
I can make 205 I think it's totally
possible I've always been against it but
now I'm thinking about it just kidding
buddy man he's he is a monster
terrifying a monster to see how far he
sent the Overeem's head yeah it was just
backwards and that one photo that's like
an iconic that's probably the the most
iconic at least in my mind or epic
heavyweight fighting MMA fighting photo
that there is I mean with the things had
to knock back that way and I mean it
just looked like such a power I mean it
was a powerful punch but the timing of
that shot it was just incredible you see
that one where his head is just yeah
knock back man scary scary dude I put
that one of my Instagram feet to that
that picture seems like the coming of
the new king you know what I mean like
obviously he's got a beat steep a Miocic
but if you want to like look at a
picture like in history when you come
back and go this is the moment we're in
Ghana arrived and people realize like
holy [ __ ] like this guy is for real he
didn't just do that to any guy he did
that to Aleister [ __ ] overran
yeah k1 kickboxing world champion yeah
Strikeforce world champion just a stud
like elite fighter yeah number one
heavyweight contender yeah well you you
and Burton were talking about it last
week on the show here you guys saying if
he starches him and if he can if he can
prove himself and it's like man he just
did it the best way possible way he did
it it's like the whole world is noticing
like I saw it on CNN I saw it on all
these different websites and they're
just everyone's just raving like he
could be the next big thing and I think
that's gonna put them on the map now
that everybody knows and they have this
highlight reel of his knockouts now yeah
and so the advertise a fight between him
and steep a I think it's gonna be
gigantic yeah I think it's gonna be huge
I've been able to talk to with steep
based coach and there's a potential is
going to go out and help them in this
training camp so hopefully that so
happens my schedules kind of crazy but
hopefully I can get up there for a week
sneak up there yeah I'm happy for ste
pay to get a big fight yeah for sure and
if he wins against in Ghana I mean that
is just gigantic that would be
absolutely phenomenal there's a guy that
can do it yes deep a for sure well he's
the champ just a champ for a reason but
he's got a lot of work to do
it is so big got a weather that storm it
put him up against the cage where I'm
out pummel I mean just just get really
heavy on him and tire amount digging the
deep waters put him on his back
Overeem did get him up against the cage
scream lunged at him clinched with him
got him up against cage but couldn't do
a goddamn thing with them no I think a
little difference is steep a having that
whole American wrestling background you
know I'd swim there a little bit this is
crazy he's opening up is the betting
favorite over the heavyweight champion
steep a Miocic
I mean this isn't amazing I mean I get
it I understand but that is pretty
incredible that he's the betting
favorite I just look at his comment that
do MMA math over so but the the common
opponent with Hellman over him and you
know how they both performed against him
yeah well Overeem did catch d bay and
and had him stunned and knocked him on
his ass and then Steve Bay came back and
won but you know he's gonna be obviously
super aware of how dangerous it is to
connect with in Ghana he's gonna
obviously try to stay on the outside and
when he closes the distance close
distance get that clinch get him up
against the cage and figure out some way
to get that guy down or where his legs
out or do something we don't know what
happens when in Ghana goes into the
third fourth and fifth round right
if anybody can even physically take him
there yeah I do love how steep it has
that killer instinct both against over
him after getting hurt
even for doom after this leg injury
being able Santos oh sorry yeah you're
right it does on this fight yeah he's a
dos Santos had kicked his leg pretty
hard and giant swelling on his leg yeah
yeah then you come back and just knock
him out the way that he did was just
beautiful yeah this was even if he gets
hurt if he doesn't get put out and he's
hurt you can still you can still turn on
that killer instinct and put him away
yeah it's gonna be exciting like
watching this fight I'm I'm amped for it
this is one of the the big heavyweight
fights recently that I'm just so stoked
for